i mean out of the blue very good nice
man called scott strowman uh who
composed the score um plucked my my play
from oblivion and said this will make a
great opera and i thought he must be
pulling my leg you know um it was just
it was a fairly intimate play um with
richard wilson in the main part about an
awful family weekend where everything
goes wrong
um and he said this will make a
wonderful opera and i said well well all
right if you're that keen
showed me and he has done that he's uh
consistently sort of stuck with the idea
for about um uh throughout the covered
time and it's on with we i think we're
six professionals all the rest are
amateur singers with the hybrid opera
theater and it's a huge excitement and
it's actually rather better dare i say
than the play
so when was the play originally on you
said back in the in the 90s a long time
ago then
in the 1990s before everything was
invented um 1994 it was on in the west
end and say with richard wilson um
excellently playing the the central park
the grumpy old man mostly based on my
year old dad
really so i mean no better man so he was
uh richard wilson was in his pomp then
as victor meldry of course so i'm sure
that was a a huge hit when it was on and
so so tell us about the the central
character stephen frebble um you say
based based on your own family
background
yeah it's stephen febble actually if
rebel was
the observer misprint i have to say well
that's what i read the good old granny
had statements
yes of course no no no i'm not blaming
you damn it for your um
fable is is based
based loosely on my father but he is
really based on all those
um
grandparents get to a certain age and
get very set in their ways and don't
like things to change
and the family come
far too regularly back to their little
house in suffolk um for his for his
liking um he's he just likes to be with
his whiskey in his daily telegraph and
not to be bothered and the family arrive
and they've got the daughter who's
always listening to music all the time
um on a headset
they bring a dog which he particularly
doesn't like because it cracked on his
tie last time it came
and uh he's just generally um
someone who is very very cantankerous
and and once wants the world to just um
get away from his doorstep but he can't
you know and
his wife loves the family is one and and
in the end actually what happens is that
his wife and uh he himself resolve um
their differences after terrible
quarrels during the weekend something
good comes out of it yeah and it hasn't
been um
unseen or unheard
since the 1990s all together because
there was a radio 4 production wasn't
there where you did play the title role
yes in fact i did and uh
penelope wilson played my wife it was a
it was a great cast
um and also actually it it's done very
very well on the amateur circuit um lots
and lots of little amateur companies up
and down the country seem to like doing
it and i get some very very nice
requests to um send a message to the
cast
and i say thank you thank you for
keeping the play alive but now it's
become an opera i mean we'll need the
opera house cotton garden next
now you know what i'm going to ask you
having played the role you know the part
why aren't you in in the opera i'm i'm
sure you've got a fine baritone
well i don't know you'd be misinformed
rather than the misprint of rebel i i
can sing but i i mean my limit is
uh
the lumberjack song
which i once sang at the albert hall
which was the high point of my singing
career um and uh since then i've retired
my voice
to um more less strenuous activities but
i just couldn't sing like the the people
who sing this um the guy the main singer
on this is terrific and it's
really powerful and what it's done is is
sort of elevate elevate the sort of
ordinariness of the story
and the little one-liners and all that
into a glorious sort of epic drama with
the chorus of 30 people there all
echoing the words about the dog not the
dog and all that um and it's it's it's
really true they've really transformed
it and done a fantastic job and talk to
me more
broadly michael about the return of
course to the theaters i mean after such
a long hibernation it seems to join
these dreadful lockdowns some people are
just um aching bursting to to get out
and see things live again aren't they
yes i mean i think that that's what's
happened have been
a sort of year or slightly more of
restrictions and there have been
promises that theaters are going to open
and they don't open so when they have
opened i think you just realize how much
people love seeing live performance
and i think live unfortunately being the
operative word it's been a terrible time
during kobe a lot of people um are um
you know no longer alive so just to see
this
assertion of of life again
and performance again and emotions being
enlisted and all that i think it's done
a terrific amount of good to people
and to the theaters and the actors as
well from what i've heard yeah yeah and
so but it's a limited run this one as
you say i mean it's been in amateur
productions up and down the country but
but people are going to want to see this
one so what is it's only on for a few
days isn't it initially
it's literally on for
saturday sunday and monday four
performances but having heard you know
that the
the um amazing sound that these
singers produce in their voices i i'm
amazed they can do it for you know for
four shows in three nights it's it's a
very hard very hard work that they put
in now i've got a question for you uh
lastly about um we we called you a
cultural treasure i'm not sure you're
gonna sell yourself for the big bucks to
um to netflix but it's also been
announced today um you know and this
idea we're talking about live
performance and you know the the small
that that ability to almost touch and
feel a performance and then what a lot
of people have been doing during
lockdown which is you know watching box
sets on netflix and we hear the netflix
have brought up the entire catalogue of
roald dahl's works i mean you know what
what are your feelings about that
well i think netflix do a a fairly good
job they they have
quite high standards and to be honest i
i've watched a lot of television a lot
more than i normally would during
lockdown and a number of those things
have been netflix productions but also
bbc productions um sky productions um
whatever um i i think you know you just
have to look at the quality if the
quality is maintained i think that's
absolutely fine um but
i do i do
take much comfort from the fact the way
live performance has been received again
uh and you know i love theater and i
love being on a stage and i love doing a
performance which is going to be
different every night um and that that
to me you know the the rapport with the
audience for just that time that you're
there is what's most important the rest
of the stuff i think it's becoming a bit
like a factory and a lot i think a lot
of the
the the shows and the dramas beginning
to look one
one looks very much like another but
they've been some just wonderful things
queen's gambit and things like that
which i think have just been marvelous
so i'm hopeful
and we love seeing you performing so
michael palin been an honor and a
pleasure and enjoying all the rest of it
talking to you thank you very much
indeed
thanks dermot for inviting me on your
show